la présence d'Antoine Dupont au Stade de
France dimanche rendrait le moment
encore plus inoubliable pour le jeune
Hippolyte et oui Hippolyte 10 ans a été
choisi par son club pour être porte-
drapeau en ouverture du quart de finale
qui opposera la France à l'Afrique du
Sud dimanche soir au Stade de France le
jeune licencié du SC langer rugby ne
cache pas sa joie et son impatience
surtout être porte-drapeau pour la Coupe
du monde de rugby ça n'est pas donné à
tout le monde pourtant c'est bien ce qui
attend Hippolyte ce dimanche soir il
brandira le drapeau de l'Afrique du Sud
même si son cœur reste en faveur de
l'équipe tricolore pour moi c'est un
grand évêtement parce que j'adore le
rugby j'ai été content et j'ai été
surpris voir les joueurs de l'équipe de
France pour moi c'est un rêve parce que
alors Antoine Dupon c'est un grand
joueur pour moi
il c'est pour moi c'est toute ma vie
Antoine Dupont oui un rêve réalisé dans
quelques jours à peine Hippolite joue au
SC Lang rugby de depuis 2 ans et c'est
accompagné de son père qu'il se rendra
au Stade de France bah en tant que papa
c'est toujours une fierté après les en
France son encore multiplié par 10 on va
dire et puis bah on est tous impati de
participer à cette grande fête quoi ben
il a sauté partout il était très très
énervé puis là plus ça approche plus
plus ça devient l'effervescence quoi au
total 16 enfants et 6 adultes seront
dans les tribunes lors du quart de
finale France-Afrique du Sud une
opportunité offerte par le club de
langer grâce à un concours de la Société
Générale dernière étape désigner un
porte-drapeau parmi les licenciés alors
pourquoi Hippolyte parce que c'est un
élément sérieux et régulier au club qui
est très méritant et on est très très
fier de de l'accompagner et d'être
sélectionné et de
représenter la France et et les clubs de
la région c'est super ouais et pour
fouler la pelouse du Stade de France
rien de mieux que les chaette du club
pour ceux qui n'auront pas la chance
d'être dans les tribunes le match sera
retransmis en salle angl d'alanger porte
ouverte à partir de 19h30 super merci
beaucoup